ALISYN.
>> NATASHA CHEN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE UPDATE.
>>> JURORS HAVE JUST REACHED A
VERDICT IN THE FEDERAL TRIAL OF
R KELLY.
HE'S FOUND GET OF RACKETEERING.
HE IS CHARGED WITH SEX TRAFFICS.
THESE ARE CHARGES THAT COULD
SEND HIM TO PRISON FOR DECADES,
AND CNN'S GENE -- JEAN CASAREZ
HAS BEEN FOLLOWING THE CASE, I
KNOW THIS JUST HAPPENED.
GUILTY ON RACKETEERING.
>> AND THE EASTERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK, THE COURTS JUST
TWEETED THAT OUT.
SO THEY ARE SAYING GUILTY OF
RACKETEERING.
THERE WAS ONE COUNT OF
THERE WERE 14 DIFFERENT ACTS
INVOLVED INCLUDING SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION OF A MINOR,
BRIBERY, KIDNAPPING, AND SEX
TRAFFICKING CHARGES.
SO THIS IS ALL WE HAVE AT THIS
POINT.
NOW HE'S ALSO CHARGED WITH THE
MAN ACT, WHICH IS A FEDERAL LAW
INVOLVING SEX TRAFFICKING.
NOW, NOTHING ON THAT YET, SO
THEY COULD BE IN THE MIDST OF
THE READING OF THIS VERDICT
BECAUSE RACKETEERING WAS COUNT
ONE.
THE MAN ACTS WERE THE COUNTS
AFTER THAT, TWO THROUGH NINE,
AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW FAR
THEY'VE GOTTEN.
THIS WAS AN EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED TRIAL.
IT IS VERY VERY SOPHISTICATED.
IT WENT FOR 23 DAYS.
THERE WERE 50 WITNESSES.
THERE WERE MANY YOUNG WOMEN THAT
TESTIFIED THAT R KELLY HAD
KIDNAPPED THEM, HELD THEM IN
ROOMS, THEY COULD ONLY GO TO THE
BATHROOM OR EAT IF THEY GOT
PERMISSION FROM HIS PEOPLE.
THEY HAD TO WEAR BAGGY CLOTHES,
THEY TESTIFIED, UNLESS THEY WERE
IN HIS PRESENCE.
THEY COULD ONLY LOOK THE HIM.
THEY COULD NOT LOOK AT OTHER
MEN.
IT WAS TEARFUL TESTIMONY.
EMOTIONAL TESTIMONY.
AND ULTIMATELY, THE PROSECUTION
SAID IT IS TIME FOR HIM TO BE
CONVICTED.
>> IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT HE
WOULDN'T BE CONVICTED OF SEX
TRAFFICKING WITH ALL THE VILE
DETAILS THAT WE HEARD DURING THE
TRIAL, THOSE THAT JEAN JUST LAID
OUT IN TERMS OF, YOU KNOW, AS WE
ALL KNOW, THE SINGER AALIYAH
TRYING TO MARRY HER ILLEGALLY
UNDER AGE.
ALL OF THE STUFF THAT WE HEARD.
WHERE ARE YOU WITH ALL THE
DETAILS WE'VE JUST HEARD.
>> NOT SURPRISED, ALISYN, AT ALL
AT THE GUILTY VERDICT, AND NOT
ONLY WAS THERE RIVETING
TESTIMONY, BUT THERE WAS ALSO
VIDEO RECORDINGS, APPARENTLY
SOME PRETTY GRAPHIC VIDEO AND
AUDIO RECORDINGS THAT THE JURORS
WERE ALLOWED TO BOTH HEAR AND
SEE OF HIM BERATING WOMEN OF HIM
ENGAGING IN CERTAIN KINDS OF
VIOLENT SEXUAL ACTS WITH WOMEN.
THE JURORS HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
NOT JUST HEAR FROM THE WOMEN,
SEE THE VIDEO TAKE PLACE, AND
HEAR THE AUDIO.
THIS HAS BEEN 25 YEARS IN THE
MAKING ACCORDING TO THE
PROSECUTION THAT HE USED HIS
PLATFORM, HE USED HIS FAME, HIS
MUSEUM FAME TO LURE YOUNG GIRLS
INTO HIS CIRCLE, AND THEN HAD A
TEAM OF PEOPLE AROUND HIM,
EMPLOYEES, AGENTS, MANAGERS,
OTHERS IN HIS CIRCLE TO CREATE
THIS, YOU KNOW, OPPRESSIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THESE YOUNG
WOMEN.
SO NOT SURPRISING THAT GUILTY
VERDICT ON THESE VERY SERIOUS
FEDERAL CHARGES, AND AS YOU
SAID, ALISYN, HE IS FACING
ANYWHERE FROM TEN YEARS TO LIFE,
AND THIS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING
BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALSO HAVE
FILED CHARGES AGAINST R. KELLY.
>> JEAN, WE DID HEAR A LOT OF
DETAILS ABOUT THE CASE, BUT NOT
ALL OF THEM.
WAS THIS CASE MORE SHROUDED IN
SECRECY IN TERMS OF TRANSCRIPTS
AND THINGS BECAUSE SOME OF THE
WOMEN WERE MINORS.
>> SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS, AND
THE CASES CAN BE SEALED.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
INDICTMENT AND THE TESTIMONY
WENT ON WARD FROM THE SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION, SEX TRAFFICKING TO
THE PRODUCTION OF VIDEOS WHERE
THESE YOUNG WOMEN, MANY OF THEM
MINORS WERE FORCED TO DO THINGS
BEFORE THE CAMERA.
NOW, RIGHT BEFORE THE TRIAL
ENDED, WE KNOW THAT THE JURY WAS
ABLE TO SEE SOME VIDEO.
THE MEDIA WAS NOT ALLOWED TO
LOOK AT IT AT ALL.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
BUT IT CORROBORATED WHAT THESE
YOUNG WOMEN WERE SAYING.
WELL, TODAY, THE MEDIA WAS
ACTUALLY ABLE TO HEAR SOME OF
THE AUDIO.
I'VE SEEN SOME OF IT IN WRITING.
ITS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR AIR.
WHAT THESE WOMEN WERE TOLD TO
DO, TOLD TO SAY BACK TO R.
KELLY, SO THEY PLACE R. KELLY IN
THE ROOM, AND REMEMBER, THIS WAS
A CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE.
IT INVOLVED R. KELLY.
IT INVOLVED HANDLERS, MANAGERS,
AGENTS, PEOPLE TO THE SIDE OF R.
KELLY, BUT HE WAS THE HEAD OF
IT.
AND SO HE IS THE ONE THAT WAS
CHARGED.
>> AND SO THAT BRINGS THE
RACKETEERING CONVICTION, SO
THAT'S USUALLY RESERVED FOR LIKE
ORGANIZED CRIME, SO HOW DOES
THIS FIT?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, ALISYN.
USUALLY WHEN WE'RE THINKING OF
RACKETEERING, WE'RE THINKING OF
MOB BOSSES, WE'RE NOT THINKING
OF SEXUAL PREDATORS LIKE R.
KELLY.
BUT THE FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
WANTED TO AND DAN EFFECTIVE JOB
OF MAKING THE CASE THAT THIS
WASN'T ABOUT ONE INCIDENT,
MULTIPLE INCIDENTS, IT WAS ABOUT
A CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE THAT WAS
CARRIED OUT OVER YEARS INVOLVING
DIFFERENT STATES, INVOLVING
DIFFERENT ACTORS, BAD ACTORS
THAT WAS INVOLVED IN THIS
ENTERPRISE, AND HOPEFULLY THIS
IS THE BEGINNING OF SEEING THESE
KINDS OF PROSECUTIONS THAT CARRY
VERY SERIOUS PENALTIES AGAINST
SEXUAL PREDATORS LIKE R. KELLY.
THIS IS A HUGE DECISION GIVEN
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT AND
PARTICULARLY TO SEE SOMEONE
WE'VE SEEN, BILL COSBY, HARVEY
WEINSTEIN, AND R. KELLY BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR DECADES OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST YOUNG GIRLS AND WOMEN.
>> JEAN, WE ARE GETTING IN MORE
INFORMATION THAT HE HAS BEEN
CONVICTED OF NINE COUNTS, I
BELIEVE, INCLUDING THE SEX
TRAFFICKING CHARGES AND THAT
RACKETEERING.
SO THEY'RE JUST ANNOUNCING IT,
YOU KNOW, SLOWLY, FIRST WAS THE
RACKETEERING, AND NOW THE SEX
TRAFFICKING BECAUSE IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN UNIMAGINABLE FOR HIM
NOT TO BE GIVEN WHAT YOU'VE JUST
SAID WAS THE EVIDENCE PRESENTED
IN THE COURT.
>> AND SEX TRAFFICKING WAS A
PART OF THE RACKETEERING, BUT
THE MAN ACT FOCUSES IN ON SEX
TRAFFICKING AS JUST YOU'RE
SAYING RIGHT HERE.
THE JURY WAS SEVEN MEN AND FIVE
WOMEN.
IT WAS A VERY DIVERSE JURY.
IT WAS A JURY THAT LISTENED TO
SO MUCH TESTIMONY, WOMAN AFTER
WOMAN, HERE'S AN EXAMPLE, THERE
WAS A FORMER RADIO D.J. INTERN
WHO SAYS THAT R. KELLY INVITED
HIM TO INTERVIEW HIM, WHAT A
THING WHEN YOU'RE AN INTERN, HE
SAYS YOU CAN INTERVIEW ME.
SHE WENT TO A STUDIO IN CHICAGO,
WAS PLACED IN A ROOM.
REALIZED SHE COULDN'T GET OUT.
THIS WAS FOR DAYS.
SHE WAS FINALLY GIVEN FOOD.
SHE REMEMBERS PASSING OUT AND
AWAKING AND SEEING R. KELLY
READJUSTING HIS CLOTHES.
AND SO HE BELIEVES THAT SHE WAS
DRUGGED, SEXUALLY ASSAULTED, AND
THAT IS ONE EXAMPLE.
HOW TERRIFYING.
THAT DOES OBVIOUSLY CONJURE BILL
COSBY ACCUSATIONS AS WELL AS
AREVA JUST BROUGHT UP.
TELL US NOW THAT WE KNOW HE HAS
BEEN CONVICTED OF SEX
TRAFFICKING AND RACKETEERING,
HE'S 54 YEARS OLD, HOW MUCH TIME
IS HE LOOKING AT IN PRISON.
>> A MINIMUM OF TEN YEARS AND A
MAXIMUM OF LIFE IN PRISON.
THERE ARE OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
THE ALLEGATION WAS THAT THE
WOMAN WERE LIARS, THEY WERE GOLD
DIGGERS, THEY WERE TRYING TO
ADVANCE THEIR MUSIC CAREERS AND
THEY WERE VOLUNTARY PARTICIPANTS
IN THESE SEXUAL ACTS, AND I
THINK AT ONE POINT, THE LAWYER
EVEN SAID, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT A
CRIME TO LIKE KINKY SEX.
HE KEPT MAKING REFERENCE TO THE
FACT THAT THESE WERE CONSENTING
ADULTS, AND THE JURORS OBVIOUSLY
REJECTED, UNEQUIVOCABLY
REJECTING THE CLAIMS BY THE
CONSENT ATTORNEY, AND FOUND
THESE WERE CHILDREN, VIOLENT
ACTS, CRIMINAL ACT, AND THEY'RE
HOLDING R. KELLY ACCOUNTABLE.
>> ONE MORE QUESTION ON THAT,
BECAUSE OF THE ECHOES OF BILL
COSBY.
SAME THING, THE OLD HE SAID, SHE
SAID, NO.
SHE SAID, SHE SAID, SHE SAID, AS
WE'VE LEARNED.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE ARGUMENTS
THAT THIS WAS CONSENSUAL, SOCIAL
SECURITY ABSURD, BUT ISN'T IT
INTERESTING THAT THIS IS THE
VERDICT NOW BECAUSE 13 YEARS AGO
R. KELLY WAS ACQUITTED OF CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY CHARGES AT A STATE
TRIAL SO OBVIOUSLY THERE'S BEEN
A C CHANGE.
>> IN THE WAY WE LISTEN TO, WE
BELIEVE, AND RECEIVE CLAIMS THAT
ARE MADE BY WOMEN THAT HAVE BEEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
AS YOU KNOW, FOR MANY YEARS,
WOMEN WERE NOT BELIEVED.
THEY WERE MALIGNED BY THEIR
JOBS, THEIR EMPLOYERS, AND EVEN
IN THE MEDIA, BUT SINCE THAT
THYME THERE'S MORE
UNDERSTANDING, MORE EMPATHY, AND
A GREATER UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE LOTS OF REASONS WHY
WOMEN DON'T ALWAYS COME FORWARD
RIGHT AFTER THEY ARE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT BETTER NOW,
AND THE PUBLIC, I THINK, BY
SENDING A STRONG MESSAGE IN THIS
CASE, FED UP, ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
AND MEN WHO ENGAGE IN THIS KIND
OF CONDUCT ARE GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, AND THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE LONG PRISON SENTENCES, SO
NOT SURPRISED BY THIS VERDICT.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE THAT'S BEEN
FOULING THIS TRI